thank you so much for that wonderful
introduction
and thank you for the to the Center for
Arts in society and to pull ISO and all
the people who've worked to bring me
here today before I begin I just want to
ask do people prefer that we have both
screens on is that gonna be easier on
this side to see or is one screen too
confusing with both named preference
okay so this is alright I'll just go
ahead with this okay so the annual Cuban
hip hop festival was started in June
1995 by an association of rappers known
as grupo uno they worked on a shoestring
budget to make the concerts happen
sometimes without electricity dependent
on an ailing sound system or resources
donated from friends and neighbors the
organizers of the hip hop festival
collaborated with the black August hip
hop collective here in the United States
to bring American rappers out to the
festivals in 1998 mos def Talib Kweli DJ
HiTek
and dead prez performed at the festival
and common made an appearance at the
1999 festival when dead prez rapped I'm
an African I'm an African in front of a
crowd of thousands at the festival the
amphitheatre resounded with the
thundering response of the Cuban
audience chanting back the words it was
pan-africanism emotion but the politics
didn't always translate unaware of the
implications of what he was about to do
rapper m1 pulled out a dollar bill on
stage and began to burn it with a
cigarette lighter and that's considered
illegal and a defacement of property in
the United States because of this dollar
the children in my country are dying for
crack or for drugs or for bling-bling
the audience went wild how could
somebody be burning a precious dollar
bill
oh yeah no give me that dollar I can buy
some bread or some french fries people
in the audience cried out then he began
to burn a $10 bill no stop scream the
audience what is that crazy guy doing I
could feed my whole family for a month
with that one member of the American
delegation Raquel Rivera was translating
explaining to the baffled audience that
in America black people are dying
because of the dollar bill but here in
Cuba shadow one person half seriously
people are dying of hunger in my talk
today I want to consider the questions
can hip-hop a subculture that includes
rapping b-boying DJing beat making and
graffiti writing forged political
alliances between marginalized and
afro-descendant people across the world
is there such a thing as a global
hip-hop generation and could it act
politically this talk draws from my
larger work a book entitled close to the
edge in search of the global hip-hop
generation recently released by verso
books the book is based on my experience
in four cities Havana Chicago Sydney and
Caracas over a period of eleven years in
some ways my search for global hip hip
hop generation traced the parts that
hip-hop itself had traversed across the
globe the first rap song to go global
was Sugarhill gang's 1979 hit rapper's
delight' in Cuba the song was called up
any hair because nobody could make any
sense of the lyrics
likewise in Venezuela kids were blown
away by the style of rhyming and the
catchy beat but it was so long and
incomprehensible that it was rebaptised
la cultura which is the term for a
pompous and long-winded speech other
replicas surfaced across the globe from
Jamaica to Brazil and Germany where it
was called rappers deutsch as a first
rap song to go global rappers delight in
part embodied the mix of fascination and
incomprehension that would accompany the
spread of early rap by the early 1980s
the global circulation of hip-hop
through the music industry was being
paralleled by the endeavours of hip hop
ambassadors like Africa BAM Afrika
Bambaataa
bum bada wanted to spread a message of
black brotherhood and unity through his
organization the universal Zulu Nation
in April 1982 from but a single planet
Rock was an anthem for this nascent
movement that was producing chapters
across the city von barda's mission to
forge a global hip-hop community echoed
the aspirations of Pan Africanist Marcus
Garvey his mission was taken up by three
generations to come Chuck D of Public
Enemy took his vision of a black planet
around the globe in the late 1980s
paying visits to local communities while
on foreign tours the black August
hip-hop collective was formed in the
light in the late 1990s to draw
connections between radical black
activism and hip hop culture they
organized exchanges between militant
rappers in the US Cuba and South
freaka and the new millennium was the
era of diceberg rappers who forged a
politics of global solidarity from
within the heart of empire these hip-hop
ambassadors have their counterparts
among intellectuals such as Paul Gilroy
who had proposed the concept of the
black Atlantic as a space of exchange
belonging and identity among afroditi
communities that Sir Perce surpassed
national boundaries
music held a privileged place in the
black Atlantic unseating the primacy of
language and writing as expressive forms
but blackness did not always have to be
the element connecting marginalized
communities George Lipsitz saw Planet
Rock as part of an international
dialogue built on the imagination of the
urban poor around the world who was
suffering from the effects of global
austerity policies imposed by
transnational capital another set of
scholars have used more recently used
the trove of a trope of the global
hip-hop nation to express it a fusion of
hip-hop and its social location as a
universal cultural space all of these
scholars saw the potential of the market
for carrying important political ideas
between cultures my own quest mirrors
the project of these ambassadors and
scholars as I travel the globe in search
of this elusive community I saw the ways
that hip-hop was being integrated into
the Arsenal repertoire and landscape of
urban youth yet the more I probed the
more I became aware of the disconnect
between localized expressions of hip-hop
if there was something that held them
together it was being lost in a haze of
misunderstandings cultural assumptions
and mixed signals my own projected
imaginings and desires were not being
met with the enthusiasm that I would
have expected the easy fraternity of the
hip-hop globe was in danger of being
rejected as a fantasy concocted and
imposed from the west and rejected by
the rest the same years planet Rock was
released another single called the
message came out it was credited to
Grandmaster Flash and the Furious Five
web planet rock preached universal
brotherhood and transcendence the
message was an edgy take on ghetto life
from the heart of Reagan's America where
Bambaataa envisaged a universal
consciousness the message was concerned
with the specifics of everyday survival
in the ghetto at the same time the
message came to represent a profound
counter force in global hip-hop history
and it offered a lesson that could not
be ignored
this local specificity emerged as
he in the global spread of hip-hop
hip-hop was shaping a language that
allowed young people to negotiate a
political voice for themselves in their
societies as I discovered through my
travels the genesis of hip-hop in each
case was highly dependent on the
histories realities and constrictions
hip-hop is faced from within their own
societies the hip-hop nation as a
transnational space of mutual learning
and exchange may not have been a
concrete reality but the transient
Alliance alliances that hip-hop is a
managed hip hoppers imagined across
boundaries of class race and nation gave
them the resources and the platform they
needed to tell their stories and provide
provided the grounds for their locally
based political actions Global hip-hop
was always marked by tension between the
desire for transcendence and the need to
speak directly to local realities as
hip-hop journalist Jeff Chang has said
the incongruous visions of planet rock
and the message could only be brought
together on the dance floor the music
held space is a possibility for unity
and cross-cultural understanding that
made it powerful yet the contradictions
between the dual visions at its at the
core of the culture would be replayed
throughout global hip-hop history from
the late 80s b-boy craze to the corny
appeal of MC Hammer the militant
postures of Public Enemy and the g-funk
of Snoop Dogg hip-hop culture has always
resonated with youth across the world
whether through multinational
entertainment networks underground
record labels or the passing of mixtapes
young people of varied backgrounds have
come participate in this culture which
originated among poor blacks and Latinos
in the South Bronx what are the reasons
for the global spread of hip-hop what
accounts for the enduring appeal of the
culture to such diverse youth
populations is global hip-hop purely
imitation or has it developed roots in
global context hip hop became global
through both the commodification of
hip-hop culture and what dance scholar
hallelu Asuma recalls connectivities
based on culture class historical
oppression and youth rebellion Sumari
argues that hip hop's considerable
appeal is based on an African aesthetic
that includes complex rhythmic timing
rhetorical strategies and multiple
layers of meaning
hip hop is the contemporary
manifestation of an African based
expressivity of dance and
music that empowers local youth and
subverts dominant orders from its
inception hip-hop culture has always
been hybrid and diasporic several people
have documented the participation of
Puerto Ricans and afro-caribbeans but
that hybridity is still largely informed
by the black American experience and
dialogue among Africa segments
afro-descendant communities across the
Americas African aesthetics have been a
crucial framing tool for exploring
diverse forms of marginality even as
local hip-hop scenes draw on distinct
historical experiences and cultural
tropes in their adaptations of the form
but how is this different from other
from earlier forms of black popular
music like jazz or reggae that also went
global
hip hop scholar s Craig Watkins argues
that the globalization of hip-hop is
distinct from other cultural forms
because of paralleled the rise of global
media conglomerates the size and scope
of these conglomerates did not exist in
the same way when jazz or rock and roll
were first being marketed record
companies such as Universal Music and
Sony have packaged and sold hip hop with
an unparalleled intensity as Chang has
noted more than 59 million rap albums
were sold in the u.s. in 2006 along with
an estimated 10 billion dollars worth of
hip hop related luxury and consumer
items concepts such as marginality
blackness and the ghetto are themselves
commodified and marketed by a
multinational pop culture industry the
first wave of global hip hop consisted
largely of graffiti and the dance style
of b-boying or breakdancing as it's
commonly known many global fans had
their first glimpse of b-boying in the
Hollywood blockbuster Flashdance
released in 1983 in one brief film with
brief scene of the film rock steady crew
members b-boy - Jimmy casters it's just
begun over the next few years Hollywood
capitalized on the international success
of Rock Steady's Flashdance cameo they
produced a string of what Chang calls
teen targeted hip hop exploitation
flicks including breakin beat Street
body rock fast forward and breakin 2
electric Boogaloo these films served up
a watered-down version of the culture
but they became some of the first hip
hop artifacts to circulate the globe
through both legit and bootleg copies
aspiring b-boys and b-girls everywhere
saw the films
got out their cardboard saw the films
got out their cardboard strips and in
schoolyards train stops and street
corners they began to practice the moves
many MCS had their start as b-boys or B
girls growing up in the 80s the Cuban
rock rapper Alexei from the rap duo
obsession was attracted by the raw
energy and soul of the hip-hop music
that came along the airwaves of 99 Jamz
FM as a kid he would build antennas from
wire coat hangers and dangle his radio
out the window crazy to get the 99 an
episodes of Soul Train that came through
broadcast from Miami television alexei
saw b-boying for the first time and he
copied the steps and then showed them to
the kids in the neighborhood alexei
remembered the dance ciphers in the park
el Quijote kids would form a circle and
in the center the b-boys would polish
the concrete with their back spins and
windmills while others broke into a beat
box or rhymed Julio Cardenas aka el
hip-hop kid was a rapper from the Alomar
housing projects just outside of Havana
Julio was raised by his mother in the
neighboring sector of one of our Koya as
a kid he would come rushing home from
school to watch the b-boys tripping
loose and without a meaning battling and
the Rondo cardona's or laying out the
cardboard strip on the back patio of his
building
they watched Beach Street fast-forward
breaking and copied the moves julio
moved to Alomar at the age of 15
becoming caught up in the hip-hop
movement that was taking alamo by storm
he would go to the mourners or block
parties where people wrapped and DJ
after julio finished school he went on
to technical college to do a degree in
civil construction but he graduated at
the height of Cuba's of the crisis of
Cuba's special period when there were no
jobs and so he went to work with his
grandfather in a nearby fishery for some
cash to help out his mother and to get
the local authorities off his back
eventually he found a job as a bridge
operator raising and lowering the bridge
that connected Alomar and Colima to
allow the ships to pass through the job
was a no-brainer at 7 a.m. julio would
raise the bridge and by early afternoon
when all the boats had gone through he
would sit back with his friends
exchanging news about who had the latest
rap magazine from the states had they
heard this song from far side or EP MPD
in 96 julio form the
rpidos crazy Alamar our area along with
Carlito Milito a captain a carpenter and
you Juan they started out just to amuse
themselves without ambitions of being
serious artists that moment we were
living was so critical so boring related
Julio everything was closed off and
censored we the youth were just doing
hip-hop just to do something looking for
a way of having fun the rap Scala Tricia
Rose identified this need to break the
cycle of boredom and alienation as one
of the factors that underlay the rise of
hip-hop in the Bronx while Cuba
presented quite specific conditions of
economic crisis combined with political
restrictions this void wasn't something
peculiar to Cuba for monkey mark an
Aboriginal hip-hop producer in Sydney's
west side it also started in 1984 with
Beach Street
Jigen school getting some money and
going and watching Beach Street every
day cause I wanted to see how they did
all those windmills and all those mad
moves he said first time you saw it it
was like whoa wait a second I want to do
that man that looks pretty cool so next
time I'm back at the cinema again next
time back there again it's like a
religion going there every day to watch
Beach Street he and some friends started
going to inner-city Redfern a densely
populated aboriginal enclave where some
of the local kids were b-boying later
they also joined the local graffiti crew
from Redfern called black connection
from b-boying and graffiti monkey month
began rapping and he started the group
SWS in 1992 I wasn't that interested in
school he said for English class I was
in the English as a second language as a
second language group when English was
my first language the only class that I
ever did good in was art so I hardly
ever bothered turning up to school the
people in our crew were not really
school-goers
so we started hanging out from there and
the hip-hop evolved from that it broke
the boredom from the ELA my projects to
Sydney's west side hip-hop was a way out
of the boredom it wasn't the same
boredom of kids in the suburbs wanting
reprieved from their sheltered existence
it was the boredom of low-paying menial
jobs and truncated opportunities and
hip-hop wasn't just a distraction from
the void it was a way of recreating a
sense of community and finding spaces of
pleasure in the face of atomization
isolation and the regimentation of life
others like Aboriginal performer way out
at alpha remembers her involvement in
the predominantly male culture of
b-boying as a way of escaping the
violence and unhappiness of her life
wada was captivated by b-boy culture she
and her little brother would watch
breakdance beat street and electric
Boogaloo on an old Betamax machine and
they'd try to copy the moves when she
was 13 why Ida had a dance crew with her
brother and another boy and they carried
around their cardboard strip everywhere
they went
I used to spin on my back and do the
worm she remembered as usual the boys
used to do all the power moves
my brother would do the windmills and
I'd be there doing the moonwalk and the
robot I remember I wanted to be just
like Baby Love from The Rock Steady Crew
BB boys and BB girls all around the
world it was about sharing a message and
also having some fun dancing and having
a good time I'd grown up in a household
where there was just a lot of violence
and exposure to criminal activity
because of poverty she said so for me
music was a way to escape really and
have a sense of happiness because the
life I was growing up in had some pretty
hard elements my by the mid-1980s the
elements of graffiti and b-boying were
in decline and rap emerged as a central
means by which hip-hop culture was
packaged for global consumption at this
time rap movements also began to develop
in various countries young people rhymed
on street corners using a human beatbox
as more serious rap crews began to
develop they realized that they needed
background beats which often required
expensive equipment but like their
bronzed Bronx counterparts who developed
the sound system from abandoned car
radios and made turntable mixers from
microphone mixers global hip hoppers
adapted materials from their local
environment
the Lebanese Australian rapper coloured
sub sub II turned his parents garage
into a music studio making beats with
basic analog methods
Colette's first piece of equipment was a
four track tape recorder that allowed
him to record four tracks on a
quarter-inch cassette by combining sides
a and B and splitting the left and right
channels he found the break beat that he
wanted to use recorded it on track 1 and
manually looped it by manually looped it
by inserting it over and over a 1 bar
sample of 2 seconds would need to be
looped 90
times it took almost a week to lay down
a three-minute beat this was a fairly
common experience for local producers
who didn't have digital technology and
that's compared to something that would
take you five minutes to do now coming
from poor communities without access to
art schools or music lessons hip-hop
producers often had to teach themselves
how to produce music monkey muck listen
to a lot of old funk records he listened
to the Bootsy Collins bass lines and
worked out how to play them I had to
figure out how do you put this stuff
together a monkey muck said no one told
me it was all trial and error pulling
apart tracks and figuring out hold on
there's a bass line and a guitar part a
keyboard part singing how does it all
work I taught myself guitar keyboards
and then started figuring out how to put
it all together
he got loans from his brother who was
working at a scrap metal yard to buy a
sequencer and a roll in DJ 70 sampler
likewise DJ precise from Chicago's South
Side had an older brother his sous who
was a car mechanic and he imprecise
mastered the inner machinery of their
turntables by taking them apart and
putting them back together cuban rappers
lacked samplers mixes and albums because
of the US embargo against Cuba Cuba's
first hip hop DJ Arielle Fernandez
improvised a set of turntables with
Walkmans as the decks simulating a mixer
by using volume controls producers drew
on a rich heritage of Afro Cuban music
and afroditi
instruments to make their beats they
recreated the rhythmic pulse of hip hop
with instruments like the melodic guitar
drums in the heavily Afro Cuban
influenced eastern eastern provinces the
group met Olympia wrapped live with an
entire ensemble of Cuban instruments the
group obsession used instrumentation to
evoke the era of slavery in their song
Mumbi the gentle strumming of a berimbau
a string instrument associated with
afro-brazilian capoeira and the water
sounds produced by by the traditional
palo de agua give the sense of being
near a river or stream identified with
the rural roots of slaves
see Korea then we garganta st. Helena's
artificiales just a cassava can be a
miscibility logic Oh give me scooch
Elias party you momentous Toriko Neto
porque tengo papacito's revolutionaries
hip-hop culture drew on black aesthetics
and a language of black black
Brotherhood to forge solidarities
between black and Africa Senate youth
across the globe when American rappers
visited Cuba they were met with a sense
of great expectation and enthusiasm
their language of black nationalism
resonated with Cuban youth feeling the
effects of racial discrimination as
there once radical leaders pursued
policies of austerity cuban MC sakura
moshe from an animal consejo told me we
had the same vision as rappers such as
paris who was one of the first to come
to Cuba his music drew my attention
because here is something from the body
of something black of black sand made
principally by blacks which in a short
time became something very much our own
laid related to our lives here in Cuba
the American rapper common organized a
meeting with local rappers where they
exchanged ideas and stories the black
August Network brought equipments and
records for the Cuban rappers like the
african-american activists who visited
Cuba during the 1960s and 70s from
Stokely Carmichael through to Angela
Davis and Assata Shakur african-american
rappers such as Paris common Mos Def and
Talib Kweli spoke a language of black
militancy that was appealing to Cuban
youth while a black radical such as
Marcus Garvey enjoyed less support
amongst ever amongst Africans in the
1920s the black nationalist aspirations
of African American rappers were
received
considerably more enthusiasm by
population of afro-cuban youth
increasingly feeling the effects of
racial discrimination in the post-soviet
period the song Bangor by by the group
admin Asakusa presents the resurgence of
racism in the contemporary period in
striking contrast to the
post-revolutionary euphoria of
afro-cubans
who saw in the cuban revolution the
possibilities of an end to racial
discrimination boeing borrowing the
title informant of a 1964 poem by
celebrated afro cuban poet nicolas quien
where the poet lists the changes that
the revolution has bought for blacks at
mono ii described the situation in the
contemporary Cuban rappers were
reintroducing a lexicon of race and
racism that had been abandoned for many
years because the revolution had
supposedly resolved issues of racism
rap music became a voice for black Cuban
youth who did not live through the early
period of revolutionary triumph and were
hardest hit by the failure of
institutions established under the
revolution to provide racial equality in
the contemporary period in Sydney while
the Telfer also found a language for
talking about local race relations
through black music it was on the music
show countdown that she first saw Bob
Marley and she begged her mother to take
to take her to see him on his survival
tour of Australia in New Zealand in 1979
like many other young Indigenous
Australians Wilder was drawn to Marley's
pan-africanist in vacations of black
brotherhood just a few years later it
was rap that caught her attention on the
same show when I saw Grandmaster Flash
and Mel Mel with the message I was in
grade 6 or 7 and I was really blown away
recalled whatta one was for the rhyming
I'd never seen that or heard that before
and 2 for what he was saying it hit home
really political stuff coming from
another person who was black Aboriginal
people didn't live in ghettos in South
Australia they would
into white society but the song
resonated it was not always the rap
lyrics that created a sense of affinity
between black youth across the globe
especially in places where English was
not understood the Venezuelan gangster
rappers get aget es acre and Vega Zima
and Vargo's in whoops and and Vagos
omalley antes were influenced by
American rappers like to partners and
Ludacris they couldn't understand the
English lyrics but they said that there
was a certain flow of feeling associated
with the music that spoke to them we can
see this echoed in the song boca de lobo
mouth of the wolf by the grupo de paso
de todo witness at Rocco's lo que
civility arguing my barrio energy coming
from the poor Barrios of Caracas they
found that the bleakness and despondency
of the music echoed the deteriorated
social fabric of their lives
likewise Julio Cardenas in Cuba was
listening to American rap but he didn't
understand the lyrics and had no clue
how to write his own songs
one day Julio was at Pablo's house rap
producer Pablo Harris house listening to
his latest music he heard a song what
ich was under set by Fat Joe featured on
a compilation album hearing the song was
a turning point in his life corn yacht
that wayna I said when I heard it
Julio related it was a moment that
touched my heart and opened my mind I
was hearing a lot of music from Miami
radio LL Cool J 2 Live Crew Queen
Latifah Moni love but that song inspired
me I thought it could really be the
Latino American Cuban connection
Pablo copied Fat Joe song for Julio on a
cassette Julio would listen to the poor
quality recording on his old beat-up
walkman over and over every day I like
the beat but I didn't know what to do
said Julio I didn't know anything about
Flo cadence rhythm I'd never studied
music wow how am I going to do it at the
start it was all a joke but every day I
began to think of a vision about how I
wanted to do this
what was guiding me was the sound of the
voices the mixture of each and the
cadences I started to rap over the top
of the song right my first lyrics
so when Fat Joe said or barrique was
clap your hands I started saying todo el
mundo con los Manos Arriba Negros
mulattoes Blancos that was the basis of
my first rap hip-hop s Michael Duda it
was an old-school rap but I reached the
people but while global hip-hop
followers found strong connections to
American hip-hop attempts to come
together in global alliances revealed
the fractures that existed the pain of
racism may have been the bridge that
connected the American rappers with
those in the Diaspora but that racism
took a different form in each context
black August hip hop collective
encounter during their trip to Cuba as
described in the opening to this talk at
the Cuban hip hop festival dead prez
burned a dollar bill is a symbol of
American capitalism horrifying local
audiences who saw it as a week's worth
of bread the Cubans had anticipated the
concerts of the black August rappers
with much emotion and excitement but
inexplicably during the performance of
the pioneer American rapper mos def
people started leaving the stadium desde
la kaya much better than most def said
some kids on their way out we can't
understand anything he says the attempt
to foster cultural exchange and
understanding drew claims of cultural
imperialism from local MCS some local
rappers saw a gap between the
politically committed lyrics of the
black August rappers and their actions
as so Andre of hermanos de cosas told
the filmmaker Vanessa Diaz it's not
saying it's not singing it it's showing
it to me none of these people not dead
prez not common sense not mos def have
shown me anything they just say what
they say in their songs but they don't
represent that so andrew was bitter
about the various various rap
collaborations done between visiting
American rappers and Cuban rappers the
resulting productions tended to make
money for the American artists but not
for the Cubans Cuban rappers were
getting tired of the one-way stream of
Westerners treating their local scenes
as exotic cultures to be packaged for
the consumption of Western audiences the
Latino American Cuban connection was
somewhat tenuous when subjected to the
very real differences of language
culture and history the black militancy
of the American rappers was not always
comparable to the racial consciousness
of Cuban rappers black Cuban identity
always expressed within the boundaries
of an anti-colonial nationalism was not
a clue equivalent to American blackness
shaped through the fiery battles of
abolition desegregation and civil rights
Cubans didn't have a civil rights
movement that brought a discussion of
race out into the open the black/white
dichotomy of American race relations did
not exist in Cuba while in America even
one drop of black blood characterized a
person as black Cubans had a much
broader spectrum of race racial
classifications from the darker skinned
Prieto's Millennials and Negroes to the
mixed race parlors and mulattoes the
militant stance of the American rappers
appealed to the Cubans particularly with
its language of racial justice but the
categories of American racial politics
could not be superimposed onto a culture
where racial identity was not so
clear-cut at its best hip-hop could
create strength from recognizing the
parallel lines of oppression that
existed across cultures at its worst it
appeared as an American export that
encouraged mindless imitation and
imposed one narrative of race over
another even the idea of a brotherhood
that hip-hop is imagined across cultures
contained its own dynamics of gendered
exclusion when male hip-hop is bonded
over a DJ battle or exchanged fist bumps
on a street corner there was a sense of
masculine camaraderie that left women
looking on from the sidelines open mics
and freestyle battles rarely had women
participants when women did take the mic
it was often with a different kind of
presence as expressed in this song
mujeres by the cuban rapper mariana
black women rappers frequently talk
about their exclusion within hip-hop
culture while male rappers speak about
historical problems of slavery and
marginality black women must face forms
of marginalization from males themselves
the cuban trio las gorillas point to
machismo as an identical system of
slavery for women just as male rappers
point to the exclusion of rap from major
media programming venues and state
institutions in their song es BIA
las grutas challenge male rappers for
their exclusion of women I have talent
and I ask how long will we be the
minority on stage even if the global
hip-hop hood was more fancy than
actuality maybe the lines of solid area
that hip hoppers were looking for could
be found in the diaspora as global
hip-hop began to come of age hip hoppers
found themselves increasingly torn
between the need to make a living and
the desire to pursue their art with
record labels picking off a scant few to
sign and promote the rest were left to
wonder in what direction their lives
were headed for many pursuing a career
in music meant leaving the comfort of
their local scenes and heading to the
West local superstars in Brazil or Kenya
became Busboys in New York or taxi
drivers in London in order to pursue
their dreams as hip hop has started to
move across the globe they developed new
understandings of themselves and others
that helped to break down some of the
misconceptions that had plagued global
hip hop the Diaspora was a base from
which hip hoppers could create broader
global networks and build multiracial
solidarities in some cases this was a
result of hip hop artists emigrating
from their homelands usually to Western
countries such as the u.s. or Britain
Cuban rappers in particular began to
emigrate after 2005 julio was one of
seven first of several rappers to leave
Cuba he had stayed on in New York after
participating in the first US tour of
Cuban rappers actually soon after 9/11
sleeping in a room the size of a closet
in the cold of the better New York
winter he wondered whether he had made
the right decision he was not an athlete
or a professional musician with a future
in the US or even someone with family in
the States to look out for him he was
poor in black one of the stars of a
movement that came up from nothing but
Julio's encounter with Latino artisan
and metropolis provided the ground for
new collaborations julio co-wrote a
player placenta with Latino poet Paul
Flores that dramatizes the dissonance
they feel in each other's spaces they
are both minorities but Flores is seen
as the rich tourist in Havana while
Cardenas has the privileges of education
health care and social mobility under
the Cuban Revolution that are not
available to marginalize Latinos the
Latino American Cuban connection that
Julio first imagined when he heard Borak
was on the set seemed to have a better
chance of being realized when Cubans and
Latinos could live in each other's
spaces and acknowledge their differences
the story of the global spread of
hip-hop is itself one of movement a
movement of ideas a movement of
commodities a movement of people if
there is anything that marks this
movement moment it isn't as much the
motion and mobility that connect people
as it is the boundaries and borders that
divide hip-hop is a force defined by
rupture and flow and it remains to be
seen whether global hip-hop is can
reinvent themselves in the Diaspora and
build enduring links with their homeland
so okay so I sort of begin the the
Chicago chapter by saying that's kind of
where I landed up when I landed in the
u.s. I went to I went to the University
of Chicago and then the people that I
met were of course much further south
and than the University of Chicago and
to me it was striking it was the first
time I was coming directly from Sydney
Australia to the US and this was the
first thing that I encountered was
extreme segregation between the
privileged world of the University and
its immediate environs and then all the
world much further south of of the
University and and I think that was
something that really struck me was
seeing and Chicago itself is a very
segregated City but I guess coming from
a different context where you don't
openly see that kind of segregation was
just really really shocking to me and so
that that that chapter really talks
about how you know I went from that
particular situation even trying to find
you know looking for rappers and looking
for hip-hop culture within the
university where of course I whenever
the administration would bring any rap
groups onto campus it was always heavily
under surveillance and we've you know as
if rap music is something different to
any other culture that they'll bring
onto the campus and of course trying to
keep out the local community which is a
big part of the university's development
policies and and so actually I ended up
connecting with where the rappers and
rap groups who lived in the Hyde Park
area of the University but were part of
the more long-term communities and so
just learning about you know the whole
history of how hip-hop developed in
Chicago and also to some extent looking
at its continuity with earlier forms so
Chicago is of course known for the blues
and known for house music and and these
two forms you know did have more
resonance within the Southside
communities but what happened with
hip-hop was as deindustrialization hit
the Southside and all of the
you know people had to leave because
they couldn't get jobs in in the area
and as there was sort of white flight
from the area most of the entertainment
venues move from the south side to the
north side and so much of that chapter
also looks at this struggle of hip
hoppers in the city to have spaces to do
their music because there's not really
spaces within the sort of cultural
wastelands which is where you know a lot
of them are living but at the same time
they're prevented from performing in the
north side venues
I feel like discussions a part of us
were all around the dichotomy between
conscious or socially responsible that
hotnet more
warms with the art I wonder if you can
speak to that
economy and either within the US or
especially interested to what degree
that holds up outside the borders of the
US I notice that the only example you
gave that might have been seen is not
socially conscious what's the both of
the old ones that even there the song
that you gave us was actually you know a
fairly original social commentary so
they are there examples of popular hip
hop artists and you know in Venezuela or
in Cuba who are really rapping primarily
about wealth status or is that less
common well I mean one of the things
that I do in the book is to sort of say
differentiate between the diversity of
hip-hop which from its start in the 70s
and 80s address all kinds of things I
talked about partying it talked about
politics I talked about many different
kinds of things and and what and it was
also commercial from the beginning so I
think some people pose a dichotomy
between hip-hop is original roots which
was really political and then later it
became commercialized and kind of
somehow taken over by record companies
which is untrue because from the very
first Sugar Hill Gang the the early days
of hip-hop it was commercial and it was
commercializing this is how hip hop went
around the globe so I disagree with
those analyses of global hip hop that
say will somehow global in the global
realm you see a much a much more
political moment with the form of hip
hop that doesn't exist you because I
think that in the narrative that I kind
of lay out in the book is more one where
what has happened is that in the the
sort of ever since the
Telecommunications Act of 1996 what
we've seen is a corporate eye hip hop
becoming more corporate what Jeff Chang
calls corporate rep and I think that's
something that we can definitely point
to is that you have the same old themes
the same old repetitious kind of music
heard on the radio because there are not
really many other avenues for
underground artists within the u.s. to
have their music heard it's really only
the people who have the money to pay
older to get their songs on the radio
here so that's the kind of die
I mean I do think exists now I think
between the earlier the original first
few decades of hits of hip hop in the US
and its richness and diversity versus
what you hear on the radio now which is
to me a lot less diverse than what you
hear so that's that that's just to
answer that part of the question then
the other part about you've mentioned
about Getty a second by Cosima lamp is
this is something that I thought a lot
about after doing my work in Venezuela
because I after going to Cuba and sort
of medium you heard some of the lyrics
the sort of revolutionary hip hop
artists and going to Venezuela I thought
I would encounter more of that kind of
music especially given the sort of state
of heightened political mobilization in
the country
and what I encountered was gangsta
rappers being this really strong kind of
current within the country and and and
it was really by talking to people and
listening to the music and and realizing
again that they really had some kind of
I mean they really went back to the
early days of gangsta rap here in the
United States as well which again was
taking on political concerns was rapping
about wealth and rapping about money
because they felt that like that what
the people in Venice the gangsta rappers
in Venezuela said to me is we're poor we
come from a poor background we've never
had any of this kind of thing this is
why we rap about it and also because we
want to orient our conversation to where
people are at and this is why this is
where we begin with and so you know it
was it was really interesting for me to
see this this gap between on the one
hand the Chavistas and and some of the
rappers who tried to you know take on
this this really cool it highly
politicized mode of rapping and and use
a political language and then the
gangsta rappers who often is just
narratives of life life in the body or
biographies of who they were where they
came from this is this is the kind of
thing that they were doing and so for me
in the global context I think many of
these gangsta rappers that I came across
we're trying to come back to the early
days of what they saw is going to rap in
the US as maintaining some kind of
stance whether political or whatever you
might call it but
as compared to the sort of almost
one-dimensional just obsession with
wealth and gaining wealth that that
people's that you would see in the later
part of corporate rep so yeah curious
about how hip-hop maintains an
association with poverty and
marginalization and a lot of people may
encounter it as coming from a what place
of wealth and power
particularly thinking about places like
India Singapore Hong Kong it seems that
there are locations in which hip-hop is
associated with being very bourgeois and
sort of connected to foreignness with a
different sort of meaning and so I'm
wondering what other ways of
understanding music and discourses about
race have to be there for hip-hop to be
interpretable as about being black as
opposed to about the u.s. their global
connection of a different sort well
that's I mean I my parents are from
India and when I went back there I
remember seeing the very first thing
time I ever came across hip-hop was a DJ
battle in the car Joe tell which is like
most wealthiest hotels in in this in in
Delhi and I was just thinking I mean it
was just really amazing to me to think
how something that especially in
Australia which is where I come across
people that was always out in out in the
West which is a much poorer immigrant
and Aboriginal areas of the city to come
to India and see it in a very you know
hotel where you probably have to pay $40
to get in and clearly it was only kids
with with a lot of money who could even
get in there and see that that battle so
I think I mean this has always been a
tension within global hip-hop I think in
all places and and and you know it's
it's been often people who had family
abroad who could bring in the latest
music who had it access to it so I don't
think it's true that you know we can't
necessarily say that hip-hop necessarily
went from one marginalized community to
another and that's how its spread across
the globe was always through poor people
I don't think that's true I think often
it it did spread through the
commoditization of hip-hop through these
channels of wealth and privilege and
and then in different ways you know
depending on specific histories that
sort of filtered down and in the
Venezuela chapter I actually look at one
of the main figures in Venezuelan
hip-hop who's a DJ called DJ firmeza who
grew up because his mother was doing a
PhD at NYU and he grew up in the in the
in the village and and that's where he
heard hip hop and and he's quite an
interesting character because he said
you know in the interview he says I'm
the one responsible for hip hop in
Venezuela I invented it here it's only
because of me that people know about it
and yet in all the other interviews I
did there were people saying back in the
80s you know we heard Run DMC we heard
this with us as we were we were already
b-boying and yet there's this attempt to
kind of rewrite you know the history and
I find this in many places where people
particularly people with privilege who
have had that kind of access either
because they were able to come to the US
or they had relatives who say you know
we're the ones that brought hip-hop here
because you know we know all about it
these kids from the body or how would
they've never been to the US they
haven't been to New York you know the
mecca of course they've never been there
whereas I lived there and grew up there
so I was always finding these kind of
these kind of disjunction
how
the internet and Internet hip-hop has
changed this you know the global aspects
of hip-hop because I feel that
hip-hop isn't just a thing that it's not
the radio anymore right no you can set a
timer
the exchange over the Internet
really focus sign you know they're out
like there's something mixed and yeah I
mean that's fascinating and that's a
totally different book I began the the
narrative for this book begins in 1995
and it goes through to 2006 and so for
instance in Chicago one of the one of
the characters that I look at Mike
Treece this rapper who is trying to sell
his albums and he's trying to sell his
mixtapes he says one of the main reasons
he could sell so many at that time was
because people couldn't get music off
the internet because the only way that
they could get it was he would buy the
albums and he would copy the songs onto
his mixtape and that's how he could sell
because people had no other way of
getting the music now that people can
get music through all kinds of other
ways it's actually harder to sell
mixtapes and and just for people who
might not know mixtape is what a lot of
underground artists will do because you
know they don't have any way of getting
their music released is they will
produce their own albums and they don't
have really any way of selling our music
cuz nobody's gonna pay for a whole album
with just your songs on it if they don't
really know you they'll put one or two
of their own tracks together with a
whole lot of other tracks and call it a
mixtape and they'll sell it which is
something that the early DJ's used to do
as a way of distributing their music and
so this is what these these guys do so
what's interesting is that the Internet
has changed all of that and in some ways
made it harder for these artists to
distribute their music because they're
competing now with the Internet but of
course in the same on the other hand it
has created a whole lot of other avenues
for them to get their media to get their
music out and s Craig Watkins actually
refers to what he calls the Digital
Underground if you're interested in his
book is pretty good on that the Digital
Underground about this whole new sort of
alternative public space through which
music is available precisely because the
Telecommunications Act and the monopoly
that clear channel communications and
just a few monopolies hold on the over
the radios has really restricted what
music can be heard there
if I'm still as the reserve to place
Civil Rights the u.s. especially
considering rooms like a future that is
that don't talk about status our loss
raping women
I think given the continuing popularity
of hip-hop and given how many records it
it sells and which you know some people
would argue that ever since hip hop has
become corporate it's mostly selling
records among white suburban community
consumers but I think that it definitely
whether or not you would see that's part
of a sort of more politicized struggle
or whether or all civil rights or that
kind of thing in general I think it has
to be a part of some conversation to
address because and and also because
there are people who you know the whole
idea of underground hip-hop is something
that takes off also in the late 1990s as
as hip-hop is moving in a small
corporate direction underground hip-hop
really does become an important voice
for people who are critical of that more
one-dimensional kind of current and I
think you know to engage in dialogue
about that I think is important
anything from
and others I was wondering other
instances of sort of backlash against
New Yorker America in the broader
inspired by that yeah well they I mean
that's something that happened
particularly after Black August and all
of the the tours that black August so
all the artists that I mentioned the
American rappers were part of these
black August collectives who went to
Cuba then they later went to South
Africa and what's really interesting to
me is the same criticisms come up from
both Cuba and South Africa of their
encounters with the American artists in
the way that you know they treated the
South African artist who is one of the
sort of top artists in the country you
know they're the American artists just
treat him like their driver and and just
a sense that you know they've put all
this energy and emotion into bringing
out the American artists and and not
really treated with the same respect and
on equal terms as those artists and then
just I mean all kinds of other things
like the dead prez not really putting a
picture of South African women on the
cover of their let's get free album and
saying you know this is from the swaddle
uprising when really it's from the
independence movement like not really
having these same cliched notions of
African Asst that you would expect
someone with their level of political
knowledge not to fall into and yet sort
of having that so I think this is on
these kind of levels the criticisms are
coming from and and that's not to say
that weren't positive elements like I
think I talked about in the talk the
ways that there were these grassroots
exchanges and discussions but at the
same time I think people actually
meeting the artists there were ways in
which you know both the Cuban and the
South African artists and I've talked to
you know I've worked in the context of
Cuba it hasn't been to South Africa but
talking to South African artists and
hearing their stories it's interesting
to me how much how many parallels there
are with the Cuban ones and and then
what's interesting is how at this
certain point there was a venezuelan
filmmaker called juan carlos at sandia
who decided to make a film about
american hip hop and he came here and he
started interviewing all of these people
in New York City and I just I thought
that was interesting because it's it's
it's always you know Americans go
overseas to make films or
or to write about global hip-hop it's
not that people from abroad come to
America to write about American hip I
was like why would we need you to come
here and tell us but yet he made this
film and he wrote an E and he
interviewed a lot of people here he went
back to Venezuela interviewed people
there and to me that point was kind of
interesting because it's like well there
are other people who can tell this
narrative and tell this story from their
location so
Bravo echo
what it means about 30 we start with huh
for now these are commercialism of
having to see inactive in morning
woman's car at the same the tariffs
agnostic but they said obvious trick
yeah you live
so I'm sorry quite representative thrown
it back at the first time I met her
from sattibabu with a movie way back but
when they showed that portable way what
happened so I think is very whatever
people see also right is about it's
about how if they like challenge and
they kind of a lot of supports for the
poor people so that way all that song is
a pain
no readings are people who really like
the power so they you know that they mix
that like a now they have more power
because coming from the poor people you
know
I think when it's a group is called a
darlin
yeah that's amazing they go there
because reality he said it's amazing
what keep and two times recently you saw
the four clerk these materials like
for my question is if you see like in
this coffee context
you completely like before aids in
excelsis trick yeah and so they know of
all you know like here so you know easy
perfect so just really felt like they
had a no more famous he company database
and it up what I remember I think they
they have some doctor referring to see
Pitino mix life here but they change
everything so I think that itself
everything he that they start seeing is
about what situation
I'm not happy here
that one here I love everything I am
Degas white
so you know before a black so I can to
signal chain sir it's open for the
so that's why you just see that you know
quality this addition about
before mmm but one thing that was I mean
the when I was in Venezuela it really
made me think about this link between
music and politics and how I mean
there's always this idea that well you
know when there's a political movement
it can really help drive the music into
new directions and and in some ways in
Venezuela I saw the opposite when I was
there I mean in years afterwards I think
that that's you know that's probably
changed somewhat but I remember I mean
like the two groups that I talked about
Vigo Somali auntie's and getting a
second I was just fascinated by their
music and it was really interesting and
then all of these Chavez the rap groups
started coming on to the scene and and
and to me there wasn't a whole lot of
music and what they were doing and it's
it's like you know you can have
something that politically sounds good
but musically doesn't have a lot of soul
in and it just doesn't have and and that
was a problem that I was finding and and
we're talking to Cuban rappers who came
at that time and they were saying it can
almost be too much when you know there's
all of a sudden this real you know push
to develop new kinds of groups and the
government's giving a whole lot of
funding towards you know sponsoring
gatherings and concerts and music and
it's almost too much because then all
you see is this kind of breed of new
rappers coming out who are all sort of
saying the same thing and and and it's
not developing organically in the same
way as a Cuban rap did right which was
on the margins not necessarily with
state support when it went when it
started at the beginning
I see how this different folks are
crushed in the world and one
miss Laurey
very another thing makers cannot cross
the border
again again especially let's interview
they kept their savings no spying on
people like answer your question is
number than questions like how do you
conceptualize boredom
motivation
this is emergency isn't politics or
anesthetic support
reactions
that I was being myself like a
conceptual that
so second good
engine wardens and the heart thank you
correctly
when we say bit more about that
no and that fascinated me too and I just
remember going back over my material and
and just seeing this come out time and
time again and to me there's really
something that this is connected to the
generational question right it's a
generation that isn't necessarily
straight from from school into jobs it's
it's a generation that is whether you're
Cuba or whether you're in the south side
of Chicago whether you're in Sydney
you're facing the industrialization
you're facing all of these you know this
world that really doesn't necessarily
offer you jobs doesn't necessarily offer
you community and and this is you know
why like the projects and the places
that did provide some sense or even
communities that were more cohesive as
deindustrialization begins and people
begin to to move and and be displaced
into different areas again structures of
community and kinship begin to break
down and so there's all these ways in
which people are somewhat just a float
and it is a generational thing I think
because the previous generation doesn't
necessarily use words like boredom in
the same way it doesn't seem to be so
kind of encompassing of their experience
as it is for this generation where I
mean all right it really did strike me
as well as coming at it and like I said
in a talk it's not I think there's a
difference between saying you know bored
kids in the suburbs who you know go on a
shooting rampage because they're bored
with their lives or you know whatever I
think there's a there's a difference
between that and the boredom that comes
from from this kind of poverty and that
comes from just lack of opportunities
that you're gonna graduate with a degree
in civil engineering like Julio did and
yet you're gonna be raising a bridge
every single day of your life you know
because that's the only opportunity
that's available to you
the gender hip-hop artists like the
other bar part is really addressing the
marginalization that
that Akhtar his face
what's interesting to me was was how in
each of these places like in Sydney for
instance when I first was a part of hip
hop in 1995 and it was amazing to me how
women became so involved in this culture
right from the very beginning there were
so many of them and I think that you
could say the same American hip hop in
Cuba as well right from the beginning
there was as the years went on there
were more but there was also something
in which there was a lot of
participation and and over the years I
think that women have found a lot harder
to sustain their participation within
hip-hop culture and and you know I
mentioned some of the factors that have
made them feel kind of excluded or on
the margins or just kind of you know not
part of this fraternity that they that
they see but I mean in Australia for
instance it's got to do with the way
that that hip-hop was marketed so when
it moved from the sort of local spaces
and the parties and the early jams into
the marketing of hip hop by Australian
record labels who wanted to market what
they called Ozzy rap and they said well
if you want to be you know if you want a
record you have to speak in a really
Australian accent and and you have to be
widened I mean the five main groups that
were signed by Australian record labels
were all we're all my all-male all-white
groups and so this to me there's a
really big disjunction between the the
the scene that I knew when I was growing
up and what has emerged right now where
none of those people are involved in hip
hop anymore none of the women that I
knew
another question I wanted before anybody
else leaves I want to do two things
first this patient comes to waffle shots
tonight at 8:30 8:30 8:30 this is gonna
catch on fire
and waffle shop
I guess free food would be pretty - we
love food
and we're going to be having live
discussion with some folks in different
urban areas of Venezuela in connection
with Sujatha those connections in
Venezuela and la cocina our array plus
the third iteration of conflict kitchen
a takeout restaurant the service cuisine
and second thing is if you have a $10
bill do not and never possess if it's
percent